bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 13 juin
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nous inviter
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction commence tout de suite par les
titres de cette édition à montigny le
bretonneux le chantier du futur ehpad
korian a officiellement débuté ce midi
le maire de la ville michel laugier le
président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier ont posé la première
pierre du projet le nouveau centre de
déminage interdépartemental de
versailles a été inauguré jeudi dernier
chez le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve s'est déplacé à mardi le roi
dans le plus grand secret pour
l'occasion le centre sera en première
ligne pour l'europe puisqu'il intervient
dans 11 départements et dans notre
chronique culture ce soir focus sur
l'artiste saint quentinois nicolas
sanhes trois de ses oeuvres on être
installée au musée soulagés de rodez un
retour aux sources pour cet artiste
originaire de cette région du
languedoc-roussillon midi-pyrénées et
pour commencer une information politique
à présent un douzième candidat s'est
déclaré pour la primaire de la droite et
du centre qui sera voté le 20 novembre
2016 c'est le député les républicains
henri guaino ancien conseiller spécial
de nicolas sarkozy à l'elysée il a
annoncé lundi sa candidature à la
primaire en vue de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 à laquelle il
concourt à directement s'il ne réunit
pas les parrainages c'est le troisième
député des yvelines à avoir officialisé
sa candidature avant lui jean frédéric
poisson député de la 10e circonscription
et jacques myard député-maire de
maisons-laffitte
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas encore
officialisé officiellement déclaré sa
candidature et vendredi dernier serge
morvan préfet des yvelines et plus de
300 pompiers du département étaient
rassemblés à la préfecture dans le cadre
de la journée nationale des sapeurs
pompiers
on essaie l'occasion de rendre hommage
aux hommes qui ont créé les corps
départementaux d'incendié et de secours
d'honorer les personnel méritant mais
aussi de rendre hommage aux décédé en
service cinq soldats du feu ont perdu la
vie en service cette année je le
rappelle écoutez les précisions du
colonel patrick et sécardin il était au
micro de william l cette année d'une
année heureusement le nombre de victimes
a été le plus bas niveau historique
c'est un travail de prévention que nous
faisons depuis des années qui tend à
faire diminuer effectivement les décès
en service depuis effectivement de
nombreux mois le pays est en difficulté
des attentats une prévention par rapport
à l'euro 2016 aux inondations et nos
services sont extrêmement sollicités
mais les personnages répondent toujours
présent très content effectivement
d'ardeur à défendre des valeurs de la
république et je vous le disais en titre
alors que les problématiques de sécurité
intérieure sont au coeur de l'actualité
bernard à cazeneuve le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est rendu jeudi dernier à
marly-le-roi pour l'inauguration du
nouveau centre de déminage
interdépartemental de versailles un
centre qui sera en première ligne durant
toute la durée de l'euro 2016 puisqu'il
intervient sur onze départements
le ministre en a profité également pour
annoncer l'augmentation des moyens
financiers et matériels pour ses
services écoutez les précisions de
william l il est le plus ancien de
france datant de 1947 et désormais
rénover le centre de déminage
interdépartemental de versailles située
à marly le roi a été inaugurée par
bernard cazeneuve jeudi dernier un
centre qui sera en première ligne
pendant l'euro puisque ses 46 agents
agissent sur onze départements
notre mission principale naturellement
c'est la lutte antiterroriste pour
s'assurer que
tous ces endroits vont être sécurisés
pleinement et ensuite ce sera les
interventions comme on fait tous les
jours dans le cadre de la lutte
antiterroriste sur les ans le suspect
découvert par les particuliers ou dans
sur le réseau ferré après démonstration
du matériel
le ministre a multiplié les annonces
dans le cadre du projet déminage 2020 1
million 600 mille euros seront consacrés
d'ici à 2017 à la sécurisation des
centres 300000 euros pour la
modernisation des systèmes d'information
et 720 milles pour les équipements j'ai
également pris la décision de vous
autoriser à porter une arme
dans le cadre de vos missions comme vos
collègues policiers
vous intervenez très souvent sur des
situations complexes dans des
circonstances difficiles souvent hostile
et tout comme vous pouvez être la cible
de la haine et de la violence au simple
motif que vous porter l'uniforme et que
par là même vous incarnez la force
publique que vous incarnez l'état de
droit dans les mois à venir cinq des
mineurs viendront renforcer les
effectifs de ce centre et de nouveaux
travaux sont programmés d'ici fin 2010
cette île et 320 agents répartis sur les
23 centres du territoire effectué plus
de douze mille interventions en moyenne
chaque année en france et prenons à
présent la direction de montigny le
bretonneux me chantier du futur ehpad
korian a été officiellement a
officiellement a débuté ce midi levet le
maire de la ville michel laugier le
président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier ont posé la première
pierre du projet alors ce n'était pas
des situé dans le parc de la coudre il
est adossé au château et cette nouvelle
résidence pour personnes âgées devrait
voir le jour fin 2017 et camille lambert
était sur place
le château de la coudre fait peau neuve
ancien siège de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le bâtiment va être réhabilitée en
établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes
un projet lancé par la ville de montigny
le bretonneux ça fait six ans que je me
bats sur ce dossier avec des hauts et
des bas c'était pas tu sais pas toujours
évident de réunir des partenaires de
répondre
un appel à projets d'être retenue de
trouver des financeurs ces deux grandes
satisfactions mais il ya aussi un côté
très émouvant lundi 13 juin le maire de
la commune a posé la première pierre en
compagnie du président du conseil
départemental pierre bédier
le futur établissement du groupe korian
accueillera 88 résidents des travaux
commencés en avril avec la construction
d'une extension
une nouvelle vie pour ce château du 19e
siècle et à l'intérieur on réaménage une
partie des locaux administratifs et
commun à l'établissement
et dans la partie neuve seront
construites les chambres et les salons
les unités alzheimer notamment le nouvel
ehpad sera situé au coeur du parc de la
couldre proche des commerces et du
public
les personnes âgées adore les parcs
adore les jardins et là on a un
environnement naturel nos résidents vont
pouvoir aller se promener dans le parc
et rencontrer d'autres personnes
donc pour le maintien du lien social
c'est extrêmement important
coût total des travaux 8 millions
d'euros le projet représente également
la création de 51 emplois l'ouverture
est prévue pour fin 2017 et pour le
prochain reportage nous restons dans le
domaine de la santé le monde
hospitaliers étaient en grève c'était
vendredi à dernier le personnel de
plusieurs établissements de santé du
département manifester contre la loi
santé proposée par marisol touraine
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé ils protestaient contre la mise en
place des groupes ont hopitalier de
territoire léger acheter mélanie
gauthier et michael et demi d'euros pour
ce reportage
il se bat contre les jets acheter
groupement hospitalier de territoires
qui seront installés au 1er juillet les
personnels yvelinois manifesté à l'appel
des collectifs de défense des hôpitaux
des usagers sont inquiet c'est surtout
quand on voit par exemple à man où on a
supprimé la colle dans le service de
cardiologie qui a été transférée en
partie dans le secteur privé à évêques
mots et dans le secteur public sur
poissy le transport fait que quand on a
des problèmes cardiologiques l'urgence
de proximité
nécessité ces regroupements se feront
sur deux pôles dans le nord du
département et le sud
les syndicats craignent un impact sur
les conditions de travail et une
disparition des services de proximité
dans le cas de l'économie de 3 milliards
d'euros qui est envisagé parce que le
préalable de la mise en application de
la loi touraine c'est de faire des
économies sur l'hôpital public 3
milliards d'euros c'est l'équivalent de
22 mille postes en france et sur poissy
saint germain en laye l'hôpital de
poissy saint germain en laye ces
cinquante 150 postes dont ils risquent
de disparaître si on ne se mobilise pas
il faut absolument se mobiliser pour
garder nos postes de paramédicaux c'est
à dire les aides soignants à les
ouvriers qui travaillent pour pour
l'hôpital qu'ils y ont et les
infirmières qui seront impactées partie
de la préfecture le cortège s'est
ensuite rendu à la délégation
territoriale de l'agencé régionale de
santé
les syndicats n'excluent pas une
nouvelle mobilisation ce mardi et dans
notre entretien nous recevons
aujourd'hui en plateau avec nous à
risque bodart bonsoir à vous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
vous êtes le président d'insertion
handicap yvelines alors insertion du cap
leeuwin qui fête ses 20 ans cette année
vous agissez notamment pour
l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de handicap dans le monde du
travail
c'est un anniversaire important pour
vous le supposez cette année alors cet
anniversaire important c'est un
anniversaire qui correspond aussi à une
évolution législative en france les
premières lois qui ont intégré la notion
de prise en compte du handicap date de
75 et en 87 c'est la création du fond
des âges et fip auquel vont cotiser les
grandes entreprises qui sont obligés
d'avoir 6 % de leurs effectifs comme
reconnus comme travailleurs handicapés
et en 95 l'état décide de déléguer ses
missions la à des organismes privés et
ça sera la création de xy pour insertion
handicapés yvelines pour notre
département en 2005 à loi va évoluer et
les la fonction publique va aussi
cotiser parce que elle est aussi amenée
à avoir ces 6 % d'handicapés dans leur
personnel
alors si on rappelle ainsi que vos
missions vous êtes là pour accompagner
les personnes en situation d'handicap
donc été chercher du travail mais aussi
les professionnels le monde des
entreprises
voilà alors que notre mission de base
donc qui nous est confiée en délégation
de service public par l'état s'appelle
donc cap emploi cap emploi 78 cap emploi
a pour mission d'accompagner les
demandeurs d'emploi reconnu travailleur
handicapé donc ils ont été reçus par la
maison de l'emploi et du handicap mdph
on l'a reconnu leur statut d'handicapé
et malheureusement
et en ce moment je dirais
particulièrement avec la crise qu'on
connaît dans le monde économique est
bien des populations qui cumula en plus
de handicap sont particulièrement
frappés à sont frappées elles sont en
recherche de reconversion en recherche
d'emploi et nous allons les accompagner
dans tout ce parcours là et bien sûr
pour pouvoir les placer il faut aller à
la rencontre des entreprises et c'est
pour ça que depuis 2000 depuis 1995
maintenant il y est fait ce lien entre
l'entreprise qui cherche de la
compétence et de demandeurs d'emploi qui
offre de la compétence pour la
problématique sur notre territoire
combien de personnes vous occuper cette
même personne c'est alors le volume et a
monté depuis deux ou trois ans et
aujourd'hui nous nous nous accompagnons
environ 3500 demandeur d'emploi sur une
population totale qui est de 5800 sur
ses 3500 nous nous en accompagnons plus
de 2000 après sur des parcours ciblées
nous avons eu en 2002 15 des résultats
tout à fait intéressant fort un
engagement de l'équipe très important
qui nous ont permis de faire mille deux
cent trente deux placements des
placements en contrats boursorama vie
des contrats en cdi parce que la
situation économique est celle que l'on
connaît des contrats donc en cdi des
contrats en cdd
nous avons aussi ouvert 1324 parcours de
formation il faut savoir que le handicap
on pense tout de suite à des handicaps
lourds handicaps lourds voilà on pense
aux fauteuils roulants
roulant on pense à la malvoyance les
malentendants aujourd'hui environ 48%
des handicapés que nous recevons sont
des gens qui ont un parcours
professionnel qui a laissé des traces
c'est des difficultés pour porter des
charges difficultés pour avoir une
pouvoir rester debout et donc ces gens
qui ont déjà une expérience
professionnelle se retrouvent ne put ne
pouvant plus assumer leur fonction de
son entreprise il faut les accompagner
et donc pour les accompagner faut leur
proposer des formations il faut les
réorienter professionnellement et
aujourd'hui près de 50 % donc des deux
populations qu'on construit son tissu
essono que des maladies qui sont arrivés
au cours de la vie professionnelle et
qui nécessitent un accompagnement
particulier alors très concrètement
comment ça se passe quand ces personnes
viennent vous voir ce que vous les
orientez vous accompagne et vous avec
avec elle vous aurez peut-être par des
départs vers des entreprises qui serait
à même de déprécier leurs compétences
voilà alors déjà viennent nous voir
quand elles sont rencontrés la mdph est
devenu ils ont rencontré le pôle emploi
et le pôle emploi
sur cette population particulière nous
aurions de ces populations parce que
notre équipe qui est composée de 27
collaborateurs
et très forte de conseiller et de
conseillères surtout parce que
majoritairement sont des conseillers qui
ont à la fois la connaissance du monde
du handicap et qui ont cette relation
avec l'entreprise privée léger et donc
on va essayer de refaire un nouveau
parcours accompagné dans un nouveau
parcours
ça veut dire définir le projet
professionnel voit les informations dont
on a besoin
allez la compagnie va l'entreprise voir
aussi comment cette personne quand tu te
sens handicap peut réaliser la mission
qu'on lui confie voyez donc c'est
vraiment le parcours et quand je vous ai
dit qu'il ya 1600 personnes qui sont
accompagnés elles sont vraiment
accompagné par nos conseillères le
département des yvelines ce qui fait
bonne figure
enfin bon exemple justement à par
rapport aux autres départements
d'ile-de-france est ce que c'est un
département finale mois les personnes en
situation d'handicap le trouve
facilement un emploi sachant qu'il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises mais toi alors on
a un tissu d'entreprises qui est très
riche sur les départements des yvelines
on pense bien sûr aux grandes
entreprises n'oublions pas que la
caractéristique du tissu économique
c'est d'abord des pme ou très
majoritairement et donc nous essayons
nous accompagner et ça c'est aussi une
chose qu'il faut souligner parce que on
parle de cette loi du handicap en disant
mais voilà les entreprises de plus de 20
salariés se doivent d'avoir au moins 6%
donc on peut penser que c'est dans les
entreprises de plus de 20 salariés que
nous faisons le maximum de placement et
bien paradoxalement environ 40 % des
déplacements que nous faisons nous les
faisons au près aussi de pme
alors pourquoi elles n'ont pas
l'obligation bon parce que il ya
certainement une démarche civique de la
part de ces chefs d'entreprise de pme
pmi et départ des forcément des aides on
a des contrats aidés on a toute une
batterie je dirais dead colons dont on
va faire bénéficier à l'entreprise mais
voilà
on est aussi et c'est pour ça c'est un
appel en même temps mesdames messieurs
les chefs d'entreprise de pme
vous pouvez trouver des compétences au
sein de nos populations de mahler
d'emploi reconnues travailleurs
handicapés justement en vingt ans vingt
ans donc d'expérience vous votre analyse
vous sentez que les mentalités évoluent
et que justement il ya peut-être moins
de moins de tabous à prendre une
personne en situation de handicap c'est
moins mal vu dans le monde serait parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
clichés de parfois fin de son faux et
que les gens pensent et ne menace pas
les verser demandeur d'emploi oui je
pense qu'une évolution favorable je
pense une évolution favorable par
rapport à ces actions que l'on mène
alors le cap emploi 78 bien sûr pour
nous mais le cap emploi de tous les
départements
je pense aussi que les communications au
travers du sport
maintenant on arrive à montrer leur
handicap et la performance de les
handicaper amener une un autre regard
mais je crois quand même qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de beaucoup de travail est
patent et c'est souvent ça qui est
difficile c'est pas tant au niveau je
dirais du dirigeant d'entreprise mais on
a une crainte naturelle parce par
méconnaissance et souvent pas décoller
quand on leur dit tiens on va recruter
une personne elle est handicapée et ça
pose des tas de questions
ce qui veut dire qu'on accompagne aussi
les gens il faut préparer les jours avec
lui dira collègues qui va être handicapé
en ski en 20 ans justement vous vos
missions en volume avec ça plus de
l'accompagnement en amont alors on a une
chose qu'on observait donc c'est une
deuxième mission il y as she grecque et
l'association
cette association on lui confie deux
missions cap emploi donc on en a parlé
c'est l'accompagnement d'ailleurs ont
donc demandeur d'emploi et le sam est
alors le sam est ce le service des dom à
tien en emploi de travailleurs
handicapés
nous avons depuis trois quatre ans cette
mission qui nous est confiée est donc là
on a vraiment former des collaboratrices
et spécialement sur ce type
d'accompagnement avec des ergonomes avec
des psychothérapeutes et tout est l'idée
c'est des personnes qui constatent une
dégradation de leur condition physique
qui de nature à les amener à ne pas
pouvoir accomplir la mission en amont
comment on peut prévenir ce risque de
licenciement ce risque de rupture de
contrat alors là on va accompagner
directement dans l'entreprise à la
demande du chef d'entreprise ou à la
demande du salarié à dire voilà cette
personne manifestement dans les mois à
venir ne pourra pu accomplir les
missions qu'on lui confie qu'est ce
qu'on fait comment on trouve les bonnes
solutions
cette année l'année 2015 qui est passée
ce sont près de 220 personnes qu'on a
accompagné alors personne c'est le
couple entre employés et employeurs et
nous avons tenu 94% de résultats
favorables c'est à dire que neuf
personnes sur dix ont pu conserver leur
emploi des entreprises grâce à
l'intervention et je lirai ce travail
collaboratif c'est une mission voilà que
vous faites depuis trois ans merci
beaucoup à risque bodart et à venir soit
bateau et nous avoir d'avoir accepté de
répondre à nos questions lors si vous
voulez plus d'informations sur ea h y
insertion handicap yvelines voilà le
numéro s'affiche en bas de votre écran
n'hésitez pas à les contacter chez merci
à vous toutes autres sujets nous allons
revenir à présent sur les inondations de
nombreuses communes des idées n'ont été
fortement impactée par les inondations
de la semaine dernière à rambouillet
c'est le quartier du gourou c'est qui a
été particulièrement a touché dans ce
quartier d'environ 300 personnes
les habitants font depuis vendredi
dernier du nettoyage et la nettoient
leurs habitations
mais ils font également le bilan de
leurs pertes williams à elle et patrick
jacq 10002 pour ce sujet regardez ils
étaient pas trompés
après la décrue dans le quartier du
groupe c de rambouillet les vivres 1
font l'état des lieux dans ce garage
ginette entreposer tout son matériel
pour les brocantes des objets qu'elle
est obligée aujourd'hui de jeter
c'était le ghana ont fait on faisait
dévier courrier on faisait quand même de
bon le vide greniers on travaillait bien
on est allé de droite à gauche on vend
des biens là on peut dire on peut on
jette
aucun objet de valeur ou
d'électroménager il est donc difficile
de chiffrer le montant pour les
assurances
une perte sèche pour cette retraitée qui
n'a pas pris la peine de les contacter
pour éviter la tente d'un expert et
sauver ce qu'elle pouvait conserver pour
certains habitants du rez de chaussée de
la rue de la motte c'est leur
appartement entier qui a été envahie par
les eaux je n'étais pas assuré pour la
maison donc pas d'âge pour tous c'est le
ccas qui maquille marc logé à partir de
vendredi et dans une chambre dans une
chambre d'hiver en fait ce qu'ils
appellent une femme divers qui kir loges
qu'ils hébergent les sans abri pendant
l'hiver officialisé ce jeudi au journal
officiel l'état de catastrophe naturelle
devrait accélérer les démarches
d'indemnisation pour les assurés j'ai
téléphoné à mon assureur qui a fait
appel après un expert dès le mercredi
matin en fait tu es mon assureur est
passé hier après midi
donc voila tout s'est bien passé on nous
demande des factures après évidemment un
gap à tous nos factures c'est très rare
même et du coup on donne la date le
montant estimé et puis une facture si on
a sinon bah non sans facture des photos
devraient suffire aux assureurs grâce à
l'état de catastrophe naturelle sur
l'ensemble de la commune c'est environ
300 dossiers que la mairie accompagner
dans les démarches administratives et
toujours à rambouillet le centre de la
croix rouge qui est situé dans le
quartier du bruce et a été entièrement
inondé la semaine dernière comme vous le
voyez sur ces images pour son président
le montant des dégâts estimés à environ
15000 euros des dégâts qu'ils vont bien
sûr impacter la vie du centre tous les
défibrillateurs ont été détruits et le
seul véhicule de l'association est
devenue inutilisable empêchant ainsi les
maraudes de l'antenne de la commune
écouter lors la regarder l'eau aux
justes ou à démonter et mouthe et là je
sais pas comment ils ont fait pour faire
un tel ménages magnifique
ils ont tout nettoyé la bouille patauger
dans la boue irait comme ça et puis le
lendemain manière qu'avant s'être vous
n'ignorez pas que la quête de la croix
rouge vient de se terminer
on voulait mettre cet argent comme on le
fait d'habitude dans nos faux socios
afin de dépanner les gens qui en ont
besoin comme vous voulez a expliqué là
c'est nous qui allons avoir besoin volts
et de voitures mais très vite il est
temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique comme chaque lundi nous
ouvrons une page culture avec et sephora
namani bonsoir à ses fournisseurs florin
alors aujourd'hui vous venez nous parler
de l'oeuvre de nicolas scène qui est
bien connu sur notre territoire et des
quais partir rejoindre le musée soulagés
de rodez pour cet été tout à fait alors
nicolas sanhes artiste sculpteur bien
ancrée vous l'avez dit sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines
on connaît aussi bien ses oeuvres sur
les villes de la verrière que de trappes
son atelier est installé l encours
depuis 1990
est et on le reconnaît bien à sa touche
personnelle sa géométrie incidente comme
il l'appelle
il nous explique ce que c'est c'est un
processus c'est un processus de
l'analyse de forme de prise le temps de
réflexion de voir un peu comment les
choses ça sert véhicules cédés processus
de travail qui amène dans une phase à
une autre et d'une technique à une autre
et puis cette observation d'une forme de
logiciels à la suite de deux d'extraire
des lignes petit de voir comment elles
sont et on sait tous que des lignes sont
fait ce sont une juxtaposition de deux
points hélas le matériau à imposer une
autre forme
une autre conception de la mise en
demeure de la halle de la deûle à lille
même alors vous l'avez compris est donc
question de sculptures en métal
réalisé à partir de la même base de la
même ligne étirez agrandi déformé à leur
maximum
l'artiste s'y assemble toutes ses lignes
de métal travail sur les tensions les
notions d'équilibré de déséquilibre pour
sa dernière création d'ailleurs nicolas
sanhes à travailler avec une équipe
d'ingénieurs pour l'étude des points de
rupture et des contraintes techniques de
l'acier afin de livrer une oeuvre
monumentale la sculpture pour nicolas
sanhes c'est l'art de déjouer et
repousser les limites
alors c'est bien l'oeuvre acea
spectaculaire assez grande et qui est
parti rejoindre le musée soulagés de
rodez
effectivement cette oeuvre est l'une des
trois rejoindre le jardin du musée
soulage et elle a été conçue en hommage
à pierre soulages grand inspirateur de
nicolas sanhes cinq mois de travail ont
fallu pour réaliser cette oeuvre
monumentale de quatre mètres de haut 7
mètres de long 4 mètres de large une
très grande pièce donc de 305 et pour
quelle occasion que cette pièce que le
voyage jusqu'à rodez alors le musée
soulagés de rodez se donne une nouvelle
dynamique en faisant tous les deux ans
des expositions de sculptures
contemporaines dans le jardin du musée
c'est une volonté de pierre soulages
l'exposition commence demain et se
poursuit jusqu'au 16 octobre
une très belle opportunité pour nicolas
sanhes l'idée générale c'est de faire
une belle expo
de la ferme beaulieu dans une eau qui
est porté c'est une très très belle
vitrine parce que durera cet été au
musée il ya des solutions c'est picasso
donc ça va être extrêmement médiatisé
vue je serai aussi des occasions pour
moi pour que le public un dragon nombre
un grand public découvre mon travail et
c'est la sitution c'est la cire au musée
alquines 1,8 pour faire cette pollution
alors nicolas sanhes parlait de
l'exposition picasso qui va être
présenté à l'intérieur du musée jusqu'au
25 septembre en parallèle donc de
l'exposition extérieure des sculptures
et puis l'exposition est également
importante pour l'artiste car rappelons
le
nicolas scène est un enfant du pays né à
rodez en 1965 il a fait ses études aux
beaux-arts de perpignan c'est donc un
retour aux sources
c'est fait vraiment c'est ça merci
beaucoup et sephora on vous retrouve
mercredi pour un nouveau numéro de
pioche traitement petit saisine de quoi
sera t il question
alors on va aborder la 25e édition de la
nuit de l'opéra qui aura lieu à buc et
puis on va continuer notre petit tour
d'horizon sur les différentes
programmations qui nous attendent sur
les celle du territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines pour la rentrée prochaine
merci beaucoup au sephora nous suivrons
ça avec intérêt c'est la fin de cette
édition je remercie de nous avoir suivis
rester avec nous car tout de suite vous
avez rendez vous avec michael et demi
d'euros pour le 7-8 sport il sera
certainement question de l'euro 2016
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain pour
une nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée